elon musk becomes the first person to be
worth more than 300 billion
dollars
um
not shocked dude
if you don't see what's going on
there's about 30 people that have all
the money
okay elon musk
jeff bezos
milton bradley
brennan schaab
and i don't know who else
probably a lot of politicians or former
politicians
uh they are all taking trips to space
because obviously something is about to
happen here
i think on earth
i think maybe something's about to
happen man and maybe there's like 10 or
20 people that are gonna get to keep
going
you know maybe they'll have a draft or
something
the rich are leaving they're leaving
rich people are leaving
they're on their way out
you even sometime i got on southwest a
couple weeks ago there's a little lady
in there a little i think maybe chinese
lady with a little umbrella
and right out the gate i said oh i know
what's up
they're practicing their
this a test for her she's going to be
one of the finalists
she's gonna make it you know
she'll be on there with elon musk she'll
be on there with uh
you know who else they gotta take
probably lester holt they gotta take a
brother too
so maybe lester hold or
reggie jackson
he'll make it
who else would make the list dude
yeah
maybe a cartoon somebody
you know probably pokemon or gizza
gizzard gizzard
gizzard
somebody they'll make it
chester cheetah might make that
they might take a drawing animal uh
well so you're going to need some women
on there you're going to need some
beautiful probably betsy ross
that little
knit it and quit it boy you want to come
over
netflix and quilt baby
oh
yeah i don't know who would be on that
final vessel you know i won't get on it
they probably won't have me on it unless
it's of a lottery drawing
but it's obvious man
elon musk's net worth has surpassed 300
billion dollars making him the first
person on this planet to reach that
milestone
the surge in musk's assets come as
lawmakers are considered a billionaire's
tax
man it's getting wild baby a
billionaire's task must slam the
billionaire tax proposal saying that my
plan is to use that money to get
humanity to mars that's what i'm saying
they're they're they're they're leaving
the rich are leaving
we will be here
arguing
with robots
that are coming to vaccinate us in our
homes
people will be fist fighting robots in
their front yards people will be it will
be down to very
perishable
non-perishable foods snickers
twix
um
the un says six billion dollars from the
world's billionaires could solve a
hunger crisis
elon musk says he will sell tesla stock
and donate proceeds if the un can prove
that wow
6 billion would solve the worlds
it's funny we nobody people we must not
want to solve hunger we haven't been
able to solve it
you know it's like one of those
crosswords you know sometimes you pick
it up again you look at it you're like
ah
try this again that didn't work
sometime you know
you got to have hunger in the world too
i think because you gotta have a next
you know you gotta if you if nobody's
hungry then
what
people sitting around just thickening
out
people sticking around is taking tums
there'll be like a black market for toms
everybody's all fat and fed
everybody's just ordering pizza
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one